we begin with breaking news coverage a
second earthquake has hit turkey initial
Reports say it was a magnitude 7.6
earthquake centered in the southern city
of karaman mararus that's after an
earlier Quake killed more than 1 000
people across turkey and Syria while the
shallow magnitude 7.8 Shake was centered
in pizarship that's in southeast and
turkey the Tremor hits just after four
in the morning local time it brought
down hundreds of buildings in turkey and
Syria as day broke Rescuers scrambled to
find survivors those efforts are still
ongoing well in Turkey more than 900
people are dead and the death toll in
Syria is above 560. hospitals there are
struggling to treat the injured people
in Cyprus and Lebanon have also felt the
earthquake
well we have reporters in Istanbul and
Beirut will be speaking to them in just
a few moments but first this report from
Muhammad Val
ve of one of the most powerful
earthquakes to strike turkey in years
rescue workers digging through piles of
debris in search of survivors scenes of
Destruction spread across at least 10
cities in Southeastern Anatolia
thousands of homes have been leveled the
death toll keeps rising and harsh winter
weather is making rescue efforts more
difficult
this is the S4 level disasters announced
by the offered Turkish disaster
Authority it means and it's
International uh
disaster International level disaster
Ankara is calling for International Help
rescue operations have already started
and we are in contact with every
concerned party in this regard we have
also received information of so many
countries that are ready to help we have
requested medical supplies and medical
equipment neighboring Syria has also
been hit hard the regions of Aleppo
hammer and Latakia among the worst
affected
[Music]
civilian buildings have completely been
destroyed due to an earthquake that hit
the northwest of Syria around 4 30 in
the morning the situation is dire and
catastrophic tens of buildings have
fallen in the city of selkin there's a
complete electrical blackout it's really
catastrophic everyone is on the streets
the buildings are either destroyed or
barely holding here
turkey sits on top of major seismic
fault lines and is frequently shaken by
earthquakes about 18 000 people were
killed in Quakes that hit the Northwest
in 1999 with a history of such natural
disasters many are asking why the
country hasn't been prepared
turkey and Syria were the hardest hit
but the Quake was also felt throughout
Eastern Mediterranean including Lebanon
Cyprus Palestine Israel and as far away
as Egypt Muhammad Al Jazeera
well as you can see from this map that
we're showing you the new 7.6 magnitude
earthquake that struck uh in the last
half hour just North that is the the
large red dot right at the top of your
screen there just north of the initial
earthquake which is the aqua colored uh
large dot further south in Turkey well
for more on this we're going to go to uh
synonym kosiolu who's monitoring
developments from Istanbul for us so
have we got any information about how
much damage this uh this latest
earthquake might have done
well the second earthquake which
happened in Elvis District of kaharama
Mirage was also 7.6 magnitude which is a
nearly the same magnitude of the
earthquakes that happened early this
morning as actually Turkish televisions
were broadcasting on air when this
earthquake happened minutes ago less
than half an hour ago and there are
reports as soon as this second
earthquake happened some buildings have
also collapsed since the morning since
the main earthquake happened more than
100 aftershocks took place in the area
and according to the reports those
aftershocks are between 5 and 6.6 in
magnitude which are also still a very
strong earthquakes and as the
aftershocks come along we are hearing
more buildings being collapsed leveled
down in the area and people are getting
trapped inside right even though most of
them have spent the night outside this
is the situation in the area it is
really dire and catastrophic in the area
and rescue workers are trying to reach
out to everyone and a Turkish president
who spoke within the last one hour said
that NATO countries and other neighbor
and friendly countries have offered
their helps to turkey and some of them
are sending teams some of them are
sending it supplies to help the Turkish
Rescuers workers to deal with this big
catastrophe that happened this morning
okay Senator cosioli thank you very much
for that update
well earlier I spoke with our producer
Ahmed ala khatib who is in gazian tip
one of the worst affected areas he
explains what his family went through
during the earthquake
we're going through one of the heaviest
earthquakes that I've ever seen and I
think turkey also seen
that the situation was undescribable I
mean like you you don't know what is
going on and you can feel that some of
their earthquakes that I have been
witnessed before it was like you feel
that the the windows you feel the the TV
is shaking but at this time I felt the
the wall is shaking the building the
whole building was shaking it was like
it's it's
it's massive like at the moment that we
faced it I couldn't think of anything
just to put my kids under the table and
stay there until the earthquake gone and
I was wishing at that moment to be a
dream I didn't want it to be like a
truly what's happening that's what we've
seen I just wanted to be a dreamer I
start to pray at that time to be a dream
but it wasn't and after the earthquake
just finished for a second we just
picked what we can get and we moved
outside and you can see the small tents
that I had with me that I put my kids in
it and my mother was just sitting next
by the temperature is under zero it's
undescribable that's what we've got
seeing some of the building was falling
down in Guardianship
and I've just received like a few hours
ago that my uncle and his wife and his
two children
it was just dead under one of the
falling apart yeah
so far they couldn't get them out of air
and we are still waiting just for their
bodies to be out
watching something miserable yeah
seeing some of the images come through
um from gazian tip and uh and the other
regions that have been affected are just
absolutely horrible and it's um it's
amazing to see some of these Brave uh
search and rescue uh teams going through
the rubble especially uh with the
aftershocks that have been continuing
can you give us a sense of what it is
like because obviously some survivors of
previous earthquakes describe the
aftershocks are just as bad not because
of the magnitude but because of the
psychological impact that it has on
people that have survived the initial
initial earthquake how what have they
been like where you are
exactly as you said the aftershocks it's
similar to the same first one and after
we left since 4 12 until now we are just
standing outside in the cold until the
some of the mosque was opened their
doors for people to be welcomed and set
inside in warm condition many other
people don't feel safe to be inside any
building that you can see the whole
street are filled with cars and people
sitting inside it
I mean the the aftershocks in each 10 to
5 minutes
that you can feel it sometimes it's
coming so heavy that you can see like
some of the the the items inside the the
mosque is shaking the kids start
screaming that the even the the big
and elderly people start screaming like
it's it's undescribable like I cannot I
cannot tell you that and I can't film
even they don't allow anyone to film
because of this horrible situation
the Turkish president has addressed the
nation he assured the population that
the government is doing all that it can
to provide help
the Turkish Armed Forces an emergency
and disaster Authority have been called
to the affected areas our priority is to
rescue those in need nine thousand
people are working now on the rescue
efforts
in regards to International help and Aid
we had contact with other countries in
addition to Nato and the EU there are 45
countries that have offered their help
cookbook well the Russell certa joins us
live from Istanbul now and uh with
elections later in the year I mean how
politically important is it for the
government there to react efficiently
and quickly uh to these large
earthquakes
well just uh in less than three months
the government is going to have or face
the election and it's very much critical
for the Turkish government now so and
while going to the elections the country
is witnessing the second largest
earthquake of the last 100 years so the
largest one happened in 1939 in the
province of air zinjan and the one that
happened today is the second largest of
the last century so it is quite critical
president erdogan is going to face one
of the most difficult elections
throughout his political career and the
polls shows that it is 50 50. so on the
other hand the the economy is definitely
not doing well the prices are going out
the high the inflation is the annual
inflation is around 80 percent and so we
can say that to a certain extent he's
losing the momentum in his political
career but on the other hand it is an
opportunity for the our position parties
in the country and opposition leaders
today they have released a joint
statement saying that today is the day
of the unity we should join the hands
and try to heal the wounds of the nation
so another critical aspect of this mag
this this earthquake is that many of the
cities in the Southeastern of turkey
that has been hired hardest are the
Kurdish majority cities such as the
arbaker such as adiaman and shandupa so
the Kurdish Wars are going to play a
very crucial role in the upcoming
election in terms of determining who is
going to win who is going to be the next
president of the country and also which
party or Coalition is going to form the
majority in the parliament so we can't
say that it is this earthquake that's a
very large earthquake is coming in a
very delicate time both for the
government and for the opposition but
but above all particularly for for the
people now we are not talking about tens
or hundreds we are talking about
thousands of the the Lost lives and
thousands of injured and also thousands
of the buildings collapsed and it is the
mag not that only the magnitude is quite
big but also regarding the the area the
geography that it covers it is beyond
the imagination 10 cities and many of
the cities are the major cities the city
of Adana has more than two million
people urfagante these cities have more
than 2 million population on the other
hand the arbucker and Malaysia they have
more than one million people so it is
quite a very delicate time the
government says that they are mobilizing
all the means that capacity the
capability that the state has and also
the Civil Society is joining this
efforts this rescue Air Force but the
aftershocks are quite are quite big and
just while preparing for this live we
receive the news that another earthquake
separate earthquake of 7.6 magnitude has
hit the city of Mara so it means that
lean less than 12 hours the same city
has been hit by two very big magnitude
earthquakes now okay thank you so much
that is a whistle soda for us live from
Istanbul
well the White House has reacted to the
earthquake National Security adviser
Jake Sullivan says the U.S is profoundly
concerned adding Washington stands ready
to provide assistance he said that
President Biden has directed U.S Aid and
other federal government Partners to
assess response options to help those
affected and the U.S will continue to
monitor the situation in coordination
with the government of turkey well the
EU is also sending rescue teams European
commission president Ursula Wonderland
says the blocks members stand in full
solidarity with the people of turkey in
Syria and will continue helping any way
they can
well let's speak to Zayna hotter now she
joins us from Beirut and uh we've just
heard that uh the death toll in Syria is
is now at least 371 people
um I mean the aid from the EU and the US
can't get to Syria fast enough which has
uh been just as badly affected by this
earthquake as turkey if not more so
Syria has been hit hard by this
earthquake the human toll the death toll
now in the hundreds but many many
families remain missing uh trapped
underneath the rubble it's not clear if
they are alive or not there are appeals
for emergency aid International
assistance there are appeals for
Machinery because especially in the
opposition controlled North there are no
State structures in fact it's civil
defense volunteers who some of them are
using their bare hands to dig through
the rubble them along with with
civilians and it's not just that and the
opposition controlled North there's a
lack of hospitals there's a lack of
healthcare facilities because during the
course of the war more than 10 years
artillery bombardment airstrikes by the
Syrian governments destroyed or damaged
many Health Facilities so they're
appealing for doctors for medicine for
for machinery for food this is an area
you know with witnessing a humanitarian
crisis the majority of the people are
poor millions of them are displaced so
already there was an emergency situation
on the ground and it's not just that you
have the cold a severe winter storm that
is hitting the region as a whole snow
rain so people are working under very
difficult circumstances to save whoever
they can save but that death toll
continues to rise with calls for
international assistance growing louder
okay thank you so much from Beirut